ok thanks for coming out just checking
of many people with light yellow pink
and the pebble light
will him thanks for coming can also put
your and drink and dc
else and the second day free bm is i
this so far the eye shank audio live
ok my  name is wiktoria
new york in the microsoft mainly
focusing on the security guard
step on it scopes
will my mouth country has been there for 15 years in
the security starting especially man
they had the the find you quickly and chip site
to word
the venture so austria null  and you guys
ariosto practice the staff and avioth more
what is more complicated she recognizes the
second one and the underlay to start
has the crèche en actually quite
the crèche and is not my again here like
under ef like wi-fi wi-fi the lion
wat  why security support and t' i get
picasso manager sarah think it's not
picasso
compliance requirements on rising dat
wat definitely come and if you unfortunately
with the nursery and why we should implement
the security and down the front beings
and the subscriber first pitch the samba
organizations  teams that start always
be square and picasa fell with something
crucial explain why security are
gates and so i is a tank why
security is import and toe in terms of all
wet and the end or the devil on my show
lotion on it at least like  why we need
to ship security to do list place
we not to start pink ball de security
is routine from the beginning and all want
to try to explain it by sharing my
wonderful story so which is a story
about
american car executive moments you
pain between the job a nice car
oh my factory hall we here euro
step is working soul hello bear sam
freeline is image so when they were
checking quiz assembly line
penetrates the ear the last step on that
simply line was were by well in stable
to  de kar en ik lot like else de
c&a merkens by exactly where was one pink
mist'
where were missing de scrubber jammer en
de guy how long do you work keeping the
rapper gram there will
we in that lesson at the last last app
in the ashes  on the line that guy is just
pour just the edges of the doors to
check with the door
perfect leads to go to dakar would like to
unpick japanese guide and he has quite
hey keep had had getchar the
old village and fictional perfect and so
like your other  hanging
the japanese guide lured him and smart and
she and she like to make you
i cycle wendy design not so
chinese with a vector is tube every
other prince stuff with bee
then fine the problem like at the end and
one knows from so already  know
we in show down the problems will we
design all the problems before they occur
and peace like i really crucial mindset
what the all our comes together wove
devops will have him and he fell at the meadow and
family again the daps kate ham and
have here  implemented and hope's
know chicken and ham and has here
implemented successfully download
yes she 3 will stokes on that so let the
ball de culture and the mindset and
shift what typical stick is wet the ball de
devops the villi sinke allen de
practical of stuff
and then evening the take one more important
eng of the devops and miss i will discuss the
car girl zoë
what paul de automation and
[ __ ] on their website
this is my fair use and continuous
integration kan die news de delivery
pipelines and de bizarre auto metering de
steps what we had to do
men early by the righting description and
and salmon
will the nursery and [ __ ] why not to
automate security him i would think
offered security use of a new word
love security team be there at the end
and caesar hey guys china join to  the
production before i can go through the pen test
and gets a link right
so your je
title your shift security to the left
is turn the warp the security folks from
the controls and the next step of the
daily ultimately security guards will de
security steps like  the check-in of
the security station i check the
architecture of the security percent will
your auto met not every company is
having the security people site and then the
crèche and those i will also who
three a moment the security again eager
to  implement the security steps and
ultimate one will warn you start is
shaking we do and they have the sphagnum
security guy sony
what the urge hand and that look good
like this
and the apple ii views like
anton's carriage what weekends on lyme
and earnings already  to measure the security
will be labeled that door in your
third running
like a lower right boil down mick ink
the image god account
realizing up to the production and ultimate
you can put the piece of the security mindset
there so i just want more careful
howie the rather  the product and this is
like the ideal boat
the devil on am i him i this gold
beach triggers' al pipelines and the
image care
product and my goals to the acceptance
thijs the business product al else what
that cool and replaced word and i schedule
the production  forward and mandy and that we
at the operations all who won the
turning
zoological steps what we do in the
devil opens in every cuff with step i
can add some of the small piece of the
security
who they would summary of both steps
and eyed  did the creator it all crown
base where aang in to the decals
of your more interested your channel op for
example google
de ndc security and i've joined by dr
what keeping it short to open the devil
then keel practically is what i and manslaughter
de  flight mode links all you can see
them with the team
tick the ship your mind set a twink
is a hackers and bride on like how how
would like my application hello iphoto
high lite nature and then i write down
with his aryans and you write down like  wo
n't you be due to protect him and
there together security plugins for your v
for the
devil on my tin woodman slideshow
studio co3 choco de eclipse else of
using who hears notify you will find
free security plugins of the him see
the plugins footnote put  laik yes that
the wies plugins help you in mediate who
to see if you connection the potential
in securecode and my third practices of
your working with the groupie' you can
run the prick him drugs would basically
before i everywhere we come i boiled down
yes coat effect too  a chair de sam
standard and of course a will here my
standard will i sullen
was sea slug the security code
inca
standard over the périer and and will
round the comb i two wiar week and check the
colt in the red stories
dave the city die colton everything  is box and
handicap well especially the security unit
test points around the fret mode link what we
go then a third net we the most
important is like that it understand the gang
team management
we stuff okay can measure the colt
and well i the something image and weekend
checkka infrastructure and cold in van
station risk is the proof of the
security
i was before with which it my ali
deployed to our servers the on the way whether
i good
check the security where will i king
the pain test making the security
assessment well
little there beautiful in  first archer is
a coat eye kids on the scripts
towards leads and the accu chek with
you're going to deploy potentially in
secure infrastructure like wmp or the
public he b and open it deep in
security scan i will you can do in
there full penetration  test
what will you become kendo je can run delight
work go of de penetration test and name
of the show today one of the example you
can check your falls configuration with
ermerveen portuguese it up in your cloud
like earlier something about subscription of
amazon account pro charlie  can you
check with the cloud integration is secure
and of course we speak bal die security
acceptance test the de testing kind such
under next up to the production of your
and the production die al mystery pi the
same step for the cm steps
league  both steal and give that
young mistakes
like and all that you that you like me
buried alive cry what who replaced the fold
there until the production pro the
pipelines
some people can make that way change
is a sansui not to be considered the
production is also  a project in the
secure
will your children peter pretty simple
steps what your wi-fi have a different accent
but also go moar deeper who has the
some additional security test
on a bration die monitor right
monitor inc is a central part of the
dead hall die  know which you
in prooflike attitude and all your money
rather it is valeo
to your customer to your business by
monitor inc
oh is it will i want to get so if the
salon and i understand joost
where angel of late sometimes something like that well
the partner for  the devops
culture what we first c and became again
using the continuous monitoring' be using
monitoring' solutions and telemetry to
learn and impro and the c monitor in [ __ ]
wk newest coc curative always with old
oro giallo she is the fold correct lee and
is  yours it's the times to be
joost and then a design of none too
crazy
and after all older practically like the ferret
inteligence it some cases ben new ear
developping
sewer logo import and change or the
future something becomes the step and order de
penetration test will time the security
experts greater than a microphone
penetration testing the muslim partner
becomes archons again brings attention is
like glabel is only murder him
something other than pay you know who
won hundred percent secure who
could understand that sand and  security
person won't you to be ready to have
the plan b in case you get chopped and one
of the most important things wo
n't you remember never blame my [ __ ]
as if the security mistake and not
support on the devils mindset its wheel
arm on all  what
i give
you
the lesson and you learn a lot and new
next time you will be prepared war will
what i usually choose a white people
sit more focused  aan de cia
see the pipeline en in be for 10
minutes
arm kan a focus on a techni-cal part of
the chassis the pipeline
Houten secure of how to implement the
security tools in your
canteens integration in your continued
oliveri pipeline
en de arbil focus on  free of him the
panty management security scanning and the
customer configuration
so oh let me show you the example of the
classical wandig the classical article
fors
understand table runner how is like a devil
op english and in case 5 for the idea
there
my mind bossink law colt  in double on
my brain ears license plate ball the peecher
price and the peter branch trigger so
shitty bild pipeline
and since it's been some pretty container
dockers alpha i want a chicken per step
will be in all particle there for whom
he is on the solution which is  like
building that side one there will be batman's
it
who get that can't one there container
outings tree every to dock
than one diamond tree or iron can
toes registry and behind the bild
pipeline i triggers' lifecode release
pipeline [ __ ] creep them one that
container a match and the liemers that the
devil on my subscription
about the devil openstage weekend are so
business like no one to see the classic
roots what there
the something taiwan moss on the popular and am
to the devil on my theory feel what
ever think  i spy and and the order 4 charlie
die runs and workshops
wie het plein den fence stef what we do wie t
feature that double on my branch
until the master
the master of course triggers so a
word of
called the difference what who-who-who
release switch from the keeway always
and verver [ __ ] already so ok week already until the
production it will so this will be a
john [ __ ] you want details here
yes kut tanks
ok so lekkum en chantal word to be
implemented append a team management
de panty management  oh [ __ ] be
implemented elderly who to
the cote always of your arke meeting
the colt
would your storing the call dan the apple
store iso who not i check the ripe is
it there for the dépendances
my picasso the dépendances euro really
important part of  or the agreement and moss
on it still darrell on my have
a weak
week japan library or i we approach
we brave' profit long at kitchen a
agreement and more using the for party
golden which will never checkt from the
security agency in the company  score
actually target the clean patch
management
zoë to something
it's not come and that understands the pool
life cycle or all the patch management what
wie
us in our development and the fittest'
of of the security and net 13 syria
import and pk's
i liked living here  someone compromise
one of the light brace and can't de be
used by one of the companies at target
company at some point
and since again [ __ ] built-in containers
who the pencil on the eps louis joseph
jacques problems those services or user
tent one once a caesar  just any
other like than o who hears ludwig the
containers
zo harmony app your excellent working
with a docker and latin ham and has
fewer tracking am of the security
notch moment yes i'll be ze pregnant
importen
de choice en trainers ar also like your
interests  archer and mei else can contain
the security issues to poor countries
school
corinth the details okay zoey have checked
out
container registry for the security
would next apple second goal is to check the
deployment
always who around it with all
infrastructure is secure and this
compliant who on  the all requirements
with white fang in iping
we want to check with a solution what
who runs him pigeons is not possible training
at least already top time
security miracles image is what is already
plenty to which a love you too much
i please thanks wat huisman big  show om
if we committed my department different
teams eyecather response with the business
the management is not always financial
support only the security initiates i
if we then brings the business foil
million
will batman's was by the team sunrise
is not in their having the money to buy
with commercial solutions and operated
the demo
albertje socializing kuri a show their
hopes and open source security solutions
and angelique we noun love teams
for qua side on fresh a win chance that
the implementing security exactly if you
start a or advice then committed commercial solutions
then dream  to the photo the press to shop
but and then by the most expensive like
security solution
i was cool and great site is sodomie
and the in the cbs itself in die start to run
henk w running te de shovel and by the
most expensive like i  know snekers
a like behind the man four years need
henk smells so dirty pandemonium of
nature sing so black and white thumping cheap
hear in all cases i'm then come back
to that i start love open source
mikasa june implemented de privacy genie
die change de  understand if the team will
we not the start to use some security
price itself before i spend money hand out
and nam frank is you are using open
source solutions or you're using some
let you already you start to understand the
security culture management can the  sire
and we will become more support there is a
leader you can get the money
what i have pictures and how much be more
educated and knowledgeable and i will
know will be al what bike perfectly sweet of
you
so getting back grow to own free
solutions and like  i mentioned the
tights is really really do sol mijas
nike percent of obligations in these
holes
we have the wrong party encampment doe
is you know the devil on
the New Year's speech er
en hours dig the new package of
the new tower like in almelo  driver
again about the new just glide iii
implements what you on then pretty cool bed
becomes the finches ball the how big this
buy hall securit colt it is love you can
him a toe the app did
love you can check actually the licensing
stuff maybe they fly  bridge to show you
the open source your solution
we offer fiberglass calculated at
some our compromise later
your contrast through the gate party patch
management
just because you're like fine mesh and the
sun we already so gives the sander show which
it's not possible to
euro  the mean and the security and your
sides actually want okay that
package has been checked by sander not
secure well you don't check we always
and download for dazzle solutions
like gasp is jordi link love die trap
arabian just with a like the cool would
be
a  german white southwold there [ __ ]
cf fox is all this your script
earth no security project which ex npm
packages and ga theory and parents so
became plank afm and then the who know him
focus all the weiss wax ball
will oh my demo is fully to the own
devops  and workshops
people recovery on the de prix extension
week checks blogs and that the pantyhose for
them security issues and for the
licensing stuff okay begin implemented
who checked of light breeze
who hector aard pendants is already an old
source code and well
rianne understatement penguin again  weather
image the container and bossink erase
the container registry so and wanting to
this holding dockers so that will i
knew all these
there well use the c small one on the
practice what do you do is it right
have netlog start has the charge the
security  scanner bit slanted york
container registry dirty kenji on
container images of be security
wonders image is for the configuration
of actually love you have a figure may
be like i know exposing some stuff like
your container is can a baby on the
in secure configuration and in the  wgo i
assign the speed up your
number then we miss the faust know where
i start a and who is what all this in
meinem on you can just in the pack grande
scan your images and other way when you
become more advanced
je him right  the comes the core team will
will when you have greater than you make
me for the side any get sin the
container out of your street and end up
in the
warranties cm security scan there is
checking
for the campaign of the security and
even time container  selfie image i
leads to your cram
side one and registration
and there and love again the tools mika
häkkinen refresh need and that we have
all these ladder tools
the most popular and also used by the
microsoft her like the two sips in
the already kiss who will  the commercial because
what there is no
tm chip i'm starting to something crazy
the open source and i'm there then be someone
to try wood is will he decided to
take the poplar walls and hearing
so is pretty powerful open source
solution which can  job containers for
security wonders image is a row
sister it in seaway also it pro white
the police will know you
check if you your container is compliant
called sam on redesign coffee bar defined
by you positions and lotte van warping will
the other tick is like you  does not
implement in the cia see the pipe up
and the photo frank your security scanning oh
you also here who her focusing on a
security configuration of the cloud and
and the same application what he
mainly runs third
because in case of income the application
i'  m taking the road blows frame of was
his scanner
what you see at the security folks and i
can be also used by other like no lie de
engineers
oh what i do i a tag de
container worse'n on the case scanning
proxy and implemented  in the pipeline
something like this you know the fold
to become the application already hidden from him and
security frank's that he who if not
to check and to be floored with alcohol
configuration is
secureline compliant microsoft we have
running the open source illusion with
you scrolling on it  skate
actually it's really cute came i can t
end the practical and the partials looked at them
with blobs not only the sea the
pipeline sure if you can see what
all other aspects of the call taiga
the acer subscription security and and will
what if help  and the part-up criminal investigation the
pipeline to that extensions
one extension checking your write up
light and the former i in a cult
already said that infrastructure is even though it is
evidence for the security and magic
station actually what i gothic checks
i'm templates  for the security wonders
image is for the suggestions like
from the microsoft agency in terms of the
compound and number solution like a no and
the everything becomes kingsburg the thieves and
teams are not using garden templates
of various only the acer day get up
sounds  i'm out
literally the details fridge and right
arm template for the teams for using
their form zal that's not for me
like that an extension da's een word na
kees en neuzen sec en extension which is
part of the same as put je scrollt swb
wat  i so i check the ressort crawled on
were your solution is the gate i
check these
are security frank's what wet word they
ar and template what to word under that
solve the fold
so in my case in my demo to not having
cart and template  and will i'm churro be
theo's being nec die die get swt
extension de dan site of time is with
arcand per of the deployment of the
solution which also need to check it
don't know about this never what that i will
be man by what  die choose en
roda de de rs show
okay so who has the pink's and who doesn't
de count sam solution
en see time security person could have
had the social issues like i know some
webhotel eye aloe
all he had done have pink to the
web god  will the web goal this the
products of which contains to
erase will the web application of love
all possible security miracles image is
and i can garden hose the steps on the show
you how to find a way security miracles
images are great practice anyways the
best  application 4 mittens practically your
skills and learn more and ball de
security
both he already did from your code work also
like products latest workshop eat and
then but have the fold this in a jules
container instances oh and if you have it
apple joyce for the architect with  is
beautiful architect of the rowing
everything trying to be creative i would i
study the tyler teeth wieselwiesel so who
so
punishment will om the requirements can see all i have
to the source buy the so change this
to the website other kind of gopro bit
contains all the  security tools around
the
no down site who see our solution
basically the bad cop bits the
container images ar no cher
and the road oh this selfies in the is your
the reason why and replaced the security
tools in the separators sjors buy in
sporing  like growth and pipelines
oh the engine word the security tools
is not will break esmee offers will i am
hairdresser dam to the the attempt the social
you can guards are security tools
between the project and other reason
area that have here dedicated person
who is my  tank with security tools will
i become one do you every child wide
the separators so scope for the security
to's
or you can even take go the separators
subscription of the security and in my
car tickler i sample all the tools wat
allmusic
got the fold teenager cabernets  roc will
the ankle the doctor scanner is what's called
covering it up yes
africa on speaking to wash and the and
edges sure between the cold right now
okay
something like that light the demo totally in the see
club okay
drivers the poll posters will already be a
show is  so that the resource crawled on
it you anyway already a
presentation basically who they are sometimes
buy which contains me at boot and you
can see we have we got the container
registry were vinckx the emojis
catalan this and as if he can keep
there in stand where my  solution is
like running and died case de separated
apps product oh oh the cat on the web colt
is located in acer apple
and they already have such an image that the
pipeline
miss bears witches donk al de magic mike
a building de image
op checking van  the security and when the
attempt to the
the fold city and there is result
juliet the boot social you should i delete the
gutter no so dirty that the application
will become your kinjo bags and a test
if you want to learn more about the
security
application what we want
to check with gone have deployed to
securely and wipe away if you looking
like that the cold of the github like the
we web cabbage-aid cross an adjustment can
the container
okay lets look in my pipeline so
press too full  oh my goal for vista
december was everything else show the
classic army devops
what if it's a show you the new
features like another microsoft there's
the michael sat image i finally up to
us we two for i support jammer
for the image and the  release by blood will
my intention was okay
bracelets the devil on the pipeline
beach volley in the pity i won again
totoro conductor mess waiter and
play edge and enjoy remember with you
not the implementer preview feature
which colt multi always pipelines
so already lodge access to the  image in the
release pipeline in jan
okay keep it that way so you like that
mike is
okay we beg boat show at switch to
the white or knowledge tb or the black color
black
okay just in case white yes then hall closet
user blog or
look something like that switched off oh  yes i have
double on the pipeline
and injury also other details ok
all three hours 3 have a drink
continious integration and kan die
news
deployment urban anping the cabbage to the
master and resources like that will the
caterpillars tari is located in a ditch
to defining the set  on the bar labels will
nam sensitive ribosome place in times in
the pipeline what the more sensitive ribosome
don't want to play vote in the pipeline
the gaslight the price becomes which is not
some pink what you do
uh revenue the security the best way how
you  can do with the [ __ ] it back with
one the best at hojo hojo doen
that is of course not so nice okay the
best we love you do all your cries
were subscriber boules club and jyj linkit
love a group keywords all the
sensitive information like crown
username nature  will have the boss becomes
access choose i would disturb something better
in eps and who is she can see all have
a great the eps we window malfunction the actions
kees and the sun and in pipeline arms and
label settling crown
we cycle of the acer  keyword tool is
where a forest so here until the parklaan 1a
outings
this zal me like and al shaer username en
de pass becomes en dating back to the
pipeline
let go of red e-shop the steps
sorry
the step by step becomes online glycol the step by
step  shall i
image the solution x or is i a
soul
alan the other image solution emma
taking like the coin picasso the
work coaches full based on the shower
will all environment the seagulls and if
he surf' some of the test and
beaches where i'm adding  the wiseguys
boot like you at the de tas quite some
old and every time when i'm running
choir
pipeline i'm getting de report
integrated into them
integrated into my pipeline run and
icons i&o
de finding related to delight brace de
pendants is en en  sansa as you can see a
local you have summer critics of
nothing what that door have sam license
program slogan oil cm
environment salma that i keep the licensees of
camp by the the
cabbage name in shrimp devil on my
advice is the place where i  can try and
see
so time whether the pendants is and there is no
i de it takes an der wand ask you to
eat
and i had something like this house just a few
minutes
and now get the statistic jette de
pendants is over i and ii i a word
back at it all did and remo the how we
won red bull
will live rijbel the tights one
cosmic then can the other next up i'm
out taking and drawing
that i already have image my name publishing
lavish the container in the week keep it
already  nicest ginger
review came on the image something like that is what
i put the image and like and management
al the neck stamp doe user you i had
to think your and share all your image
to a shower and nobody de check it
for the security and the ice it  right
thing have this parallel tas tic
agency with step is is king erased
eggs queen the parabola something that is a
have an idea pendants
and it could well that i could be cause
your team can work independently and not
get the later sit again the container
security  step
okay little have the ball the fold until the
der staaij the next up you will the security
check will save the burden put the for
security
shines in the pipeline i locs following
will the security container and this is
where i'm a like going home
checking had container image trace the
wonders image is and that admitted to
dusk so vague and great witches running in
eps and seize en course i like
beaches what age of cla you can
always think that is the commonline the
physiology to speak we are single and took
conversion the comment like it to
because so this can be a little bit for the
wonders image is and if we already monte
grotesque to the a match for the police
violations
and the arlon to get old the
salts published in details of pictures in
the set reached fall will  and the and the food
and that's an artifact in the pipeline
and you can do if it says you can
always at stands results you can take
in one take out with jason en like i
know you is in the throw away also reviv'd
the team
ok so understanding forbid i the
ever wario deploying absolute and the
last step is like a
who is eyetracking for the wonders image
and eyed raven toe bag i shave tall
people the force land is the albers
scanner would critters work again scanning
k oh
solution  for der wonders image is for
the al was captain security wonders
image is
additionally always al have for
integrated al the result until the test
results all you can see the result in the
tas pipeline and other shows
and the next up is that environment god the
last one like comment share on jack
collection infrastructure
especially for the wonders biologist for
compliance for security to
keep imperfections so that it is also in
the output
am deep and the speaker offered container
or the cpi economic euro
the bag coronation successful outings
barrage  the
the pipeline iphone the belly and the e
baseline bang
they measure until the michael sat for the
checking help for him quite so gave it
something can be a fixed but no flash
the staff is running successfully i just
the bag and floated some strange
very cold  what gang on the bag class-b of
is you can see you get the artifacts and
beaches at push him who is report for
the nice
container security and river open bis
reapered your ghetto the statistic
like a divorce triport is let's take the
wonders bild somebody  if i am a very
striking one there is a seafox for it's not
okay
channel is a bit more than ever
okay yes so enthusiastic
satan that so i was promoting you the
least be on the finding so to speak
the resume database so for what that tie i
check  will the links accidentally blew as they
rolled
applications become i have in stalt in the
container all the applications will you
put it in the in the container for the
finding of the security miracles image i
send it keeps you
so all the report which contains will  i
ok
biseswar i the security finding crisis
registry in cbd bus and i us all will you
you're all of which explains om wel what
is the security other image at the time for
an online game and blackmail and the sec and
tooske john browning your site checking
for the police violations en wiske be
my girl the different police officers lionel in
nascar en queso als je great de dokker
file which contains is a signal weather
two not your gate and not she is like
he may be your case protect greet' met
you're  not pink the containers vcc
two not your there isn't over yet so
i had a goal your channel even out of the
action step will you can tune up your
pipeline even to break here to step here
based on this action so and this can
usually takes just  a few seconds i
never fast and aids like really
interesting half a billion scanning the
images okay so all those screened and the
incense teeth container step and all
about who who like to look already already
adultery scanner like oasis what happens
laugh at this management
the result  get publish it with time and
give the site need this super
eight file we already offers finding
smith fairly okay lets integrated with
a
de test result and if you can imitate you see
can find all defining
in your test result of the everything blog
okay  bici what the cookies
not having you epyon dear and all
finding
the common questions becomes al je jolie
get from the people who have
implements everything posed
then exclusion is okay the touran
speech disguised and poverty scanning and
a see what the problem is with
understanding  or integration in the edge can
i make if keep of indication gate and
yes you can implement office
sleep can toes offer the offers up scanner
or a tv show will in which case
you can see all i have the dinghy
which requires of integration so eva
foot scan it who will the advent cationic
ass fine the internal finding site so
then i just edgar edgar and the elf
indication port and you can see the
result to the results well sorry in your
testing
result and the last but not least all
game engine between the  checking the infrastructure
as i see it i always free to here
i already so i your and implementing
measures the gay
bag swt extension
eady's lot link by default i is
auction the pipeline
in case of any finding will in in my case
is j4 also other  port dust you see already
have plenty of links will agree who
is who that so that all calling to
buy the ressort
let all attempt at the impa start you
with this already will also from the container
registry something like eyeliner blue or
double chain and rose alexander  summer
identity
axis love you have done with in icy i
lok sun all your service or cissé en
quichot the best practically the best
breaks suggestions and like i
mentioned by default
first place man finding love like i
know it felt like i for the campaign or
swt
oh is there sdk i am a file de pipe and
you can change it in your tasks by
adding the
wearable wie churchill oh god what you already support
then in the nordic fire and make it
successes example anyway reason why
you see
below close the window  flat
pickles
arjo the side the like at idle hands
seize the solo show running kind the
production killers like
is a next web what's good out rent at
the end times the next always
sting the production and out of the fuses [ __ ]
so she holds to the paradox  an epic
not come my body design in that school you
that site video team
when you're starting to implement the
security
then the pot comes apart there are some requirements
just start love all this beauty like a
then break your pipeline fifth from the
left  the greenhouse if you were a cellar the
al the security in the ships and mrs
suburb the new european nash a
golden image in religions pipeline drock
security blink dat dat features
okay so if your source bubble shuttle the
dinghy
something waste is your interest rate on  the
plee ramp the pep buys and you win the pot
in azure container instances also doe
he knows in my this tool rapping
stoic other provider the links rider
and you can just follow step-by-step
instructions and also if you're
interested to play  anti-freeze pipeline
and
the or take some of the pebbles and gonna
publish the ring race week the cm
roger i would a call and look more
deeper and implemented by you by yourself
and local all who security praxis word
as excited by starting bed
and
something i shoot not take and what alike the
energy since you can have mine already
what dan
getting back to the demo step so
you whoever on the prix for tools de poor
open source tool
cradle and comrade infrastructure de cote
and we no  cabbage with apple caching
security and we'll call it also the
container
step handy suitcase to bring you my language
in teams time and hashes that i live in
the best way is already suggested i
started century lived security
i have rent in sebald some devil between
security tools of the each on the
stones or label
where I had the open source if it is correct also to the
secure there what will no
cost of the
signs of use the thief and tools of the
thief and cloud than I for the azure
what already  so from the amazon and then also a
mine plants and implementer sprite
exactly and the if you're doing old-fashioned
off than you do at bob's
other kind of césar bebel like
ln max light strike in the be published
and the echo well than you like something you
and you she full and that of the third week
how we can implements on security
practically now already that knot running kmar
in the commercial tools and she is on her
ever and i a thanks for your time
and if you have any questions on like a
pink  who has a minute tonight
happy then if you don't you
can also hearts sea life picasa lights
with
yes locations i via to show your ride
on sea you just come and speaker with you
behind and i a leica especially on the
other because i  go very young
christ see that pipeline thanks to the
publish it with
here in the week yes tanks
[Applause]